now that zack snyder's justice league
has finally come to hbo max
director zack snyder is not holding back
any details on what he planned for
justice league
or the additional two movies that were
meant to finish his dc eu story arc
it's a bittersweet moment for fans they
finally got his version of the superhero
film
yet now teased with the enticing but
most likely doomed sequels
on top of that snyder revealed that
while the snyder kurtz was billed as his
pure vision
unadulterated from what the studio
wanted there is still one scene that had
to change
things change
what do you want ah the direct approach
i admire that at the very very end of
his justice league
past the heroes happy days lex luthor's
shenanigans and the explosive epilogue
bruce wayne hears a strange sound
outside his house he finds a stoic green
alien
cape dramatically billowing behind him
who warns that dark side is not done
and there's a war coming it's martian
manhunter the alter ego of man of
steel's general swanwick who appeared
once earlier in the film disguised as
martha kent
after a brief chat about how they would
join forces bruce
desperate for just one moment of peace
goes back to bed and the movie ends
however it turns out that snyder
originally wanted a different green hero
to bring ill tidings to batman's
doorstep in another timeline
it would have been green lantern flying
in to proclaim his aid to bruce
absolutely alright
i can do that snyder said to vanity fair
we shot a version of this scene with the
green lantern but the studio really
fought me and said
we really didn't want you to do green
lantern so i made a deal with them
and they let me do this instead now we
did get one green lantern in the film
jalan ger fell to dark side in the past
and lost his precious ring
but we didn't get the justice league's
green lantern for anyone unfamiliar with
the comics
just know there are several green
lanterns at once making up the universe
wide green lantern corps
snyder would have brought in jon stewart
dc's first black superhero to join
batman and the crow
not only that but he would have brought
in ryan reynolds green lantern
from the maligned green lantern of 2011
to join stuart and ger
i hal jordan do
solemnly swear to
pledge allegiance to a lantern
however warner brothers had a somewhat
promising reason to not let him use
stewart
he said they were like we have plans for
jon stewart and we want to do our own
announcements so i said
all right i'll give you that so martian
manhunter was a compromise hbo max does
have a green lantern series in the works
though it's unclear just which
characters will be in it
so while fans may be disappointed they
didn't get stuart in zack snyder's
justice league
there's still hope for seeing him on
screen zack snyder's justice league
is available to stream now on hbo max
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite dc eu tv shows and movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you
don't miss a single one